or
l'été c'est la saison des vacances mais
c'est aussi celle des expositions
agricoles au fil des ans la semaine
verte en a visité plusieurs à commencer
par celle de regina en 1971
[Musique]
cette année la marque et le lancement
d'agréer mission la grande foire
agricole dans l'es13
c'est un début magnifique rac au delà de
1000 têtes de bétail en et au delà près
de 1000 par mois je crois que ça
s'imposait dans l'ouest canadien
madame accepteriez vous que votre mari
diversifié a vu ses productions
agricoles qui a commencé que décidé il a
commencé à rentrer dans l'industrie des
cochons en voyant ce qu'est une nouvelle
machine puis le moins de voyages qui
aurait fait là il peut s'occuper de sa
lui-même sans les garçons tous
[Musique]
pour les éleveurs une exposition c'est
l'occasion de montrer ses plus beaux
animaux et de prendre part à des
concours
[Musique]
en 1981 l'expo de saint-hyacinthe
accueillait deux cent mille visiteurs
bien dit c'est avec des gens cela vienne
des gens de montréal m à venir la scène
ça st il trouve c'est réellement de
l'agriculture
[Musique]
les rubans surtout chez des éleveurs
sont souvent la principale récompense
accordée par les foires
[Musique]
plusieurs expositions au pays ont une
longue histoire ancrée dans notre passé
agricole celle de bronze remonte à 1856
la coved a forcé l'annulation de
plusieurs de ces rendez-vous en 2020 et
l'été à venir s'annoncent toujours
incertain
[Musique]
oh